On February 6th, 2012, Chinese police surrounded
the U.S. Consulate in Chengdu, China in a
tense, 30-hour standoff.
Inside, Wang Lijun frantically pled for asylum
as he presented evidence of what would become
the nation’s biggest scandal in decades.
As police chief of the country’s 3rd largest
city, Wang possessed documents, he said, which
could bring down his boss and one of the most
powerful men in China, Bo Xilai.
It all revolved around a British businessman
named Neil Heywood.
In exchange for getting Bo’s son into a
prestigious boarding school, Heywood was rewarded
with political favors.
But, for reasons that are still unclear, Bo’s
wife grew frustrated, and eventually poisoned
the man.
Dramatic, Oscar-worthy stories like this one
are a dime a dozen in China.
In 2019, for example, this video circulated
on social media, showing 13 and a half tonnes
of gold hidden in a party secretary’s home.
Between 2012 and 17 alone, 1.5 million officials
were disciplined for corruption.
That’s nearly 700 criminal charges, demotions,
and dismissals every single day for six straight
years.
It should be no surprise, then, that China
has, quote, “serious corruption problems”
according to Transparency International.
But, here’s what is surprising…
Take each country and place it on a line from
most to least corrupt.
Now, on the x-axis, show its economic growth.
What emerges is the general trend you’d
expect: the less corruption, the stronger
an economy.
Corruption, after all, is a tax on business.
It scares away investors and diverts limited
resources toward unproductive roads to nowhere.
…And yet, China is wayyy over here — with
both extremely high growth and corruption.
How is that possible?
How has China defied predictions of imminent
economic collapse every single year for decades?
Not by eliminating corruption but by doing
what no other country has managed to do so
effectively: weaponizing it.
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula, where
you can watch my brand new Nebula Original
series.
This first full-length episode is about how
Chinese censorship actually works and why
the regime does sometimes tolerate dissent.
Watch it with the CuriosityStream and Nebula
bundle, right now 42% off for Mother’s Day
— just $12/year.
If you enjoy these videos, sign up to essentially
get 50% more of them starting today.
On the very first day of Finance 101, students
are taught about the “Principal-Agent Problem”.
Capitalism, it goes, is all about specialization
— it isn’t efficient, or even possible
for each of us to sew our own clothes, solder
our own electronics, and be our own doctors.
So we outsource each of these jobs to someone
more qualified.
Modern life, in other words, requires delegation.
But how do a company’s shareholders ensure
its managers, who they delegate decision-making
to, don’t misuse their money?
Replace ‘shareholders’ with voters and
‘managers’ with politicians, and you understand
why eliminating corruption is a really hard
problem.
That’s in a democracy.
But even the most iron-fisted dictator can’t
possibly make, much less implement every last
decision on their own.
They too must delegate.
Say you’re the leader of China.
Whether or not you have the people’s best
interest in mind, you also know your legitimacy,
and therefore, your power, depends on some
level of competence.
While nationalism and censorship afford the
Communist Party plenty of room for failure,
at the end of the day, your continued rule
requires food on the table, gas in the tank,
and at least some occasional clean water.
On a purely organizational level, take a second
to appreciate just how hard a coordination
problem it is to convert words, at the top,
into the actions, 99-layers below, which result
in more high speed rail than every other country
put together, and maintain 10% GDP growth
for years on end.
Now, for the sake of simplicity, let’s condense
those (hypothetical) 99 layers into just three.
At the very top of the pyramid are a tiny
number of elite party officials.
Getting them to follow orders is relatively
easy — their next promotion depends on it.
The problem lies between them and the public
— the ground-level civil servants who, on
any given day, actually deliver the functions
of ‘government’ — providing healthcare,
delivering education, and building infrastructure.
Unlike the elites, these officials are usually
stationed in one city for their entire careers.
They aren’t playing some “House of Cards”
game of political intrigue, they’re just
looking to put food on the table.
And, hey, if they can convert what authority
they have into a new car or apartment, even
better!
…And therein lies the problem.
The Chinese bureaucracy is huge.
We’re talking 50 million party-state employees
— aka all of South Korea, or Texas and New
York put together.
That’s excluding its military — the world’s
largest, and State-Owned-Enterprises, which
comprise nine of the country’s ten largest
employers.
Plus that number is from 2007.
Meanwhile, thanks to outdated rules and widespread
evasion, only 2% of the population paid any
income tax in 2015, according to one former
official.
In other words, there just isn’t enough
revenue to go around.
Public servants are paid peanuts.
The average nationwide monthly wage is $1,298
US dollars, yet the highest-paid civil servants
make just $824 and the lowest, a measly 80.
This is a dangerous combination — lots of
local political power, yet, thanks to desperation,
every incentive to hinder and steal rather
than help the country.
How do you convince these local officials,
who may not even make a living wage, to stop
harassing businesses, which you, the leader,
need to create the jobs and drive the economic
growth that keeps you in power?
Countries unable to answer this question end
up like the Philippines, paralyzed against
their will by an endless cycle of incompetence
and corruption.
One obvious solution is to do as Singapore
does — pay them so much that they don’t
have to resort to bribery.
Members of its parliament are given a monthly
allowance three times higher than the median
household income and its Prime Minister is
the world’s highest-paid political leader
— earning four times as much as the U.S.
president.
The results are compelling: no politician
has been charged with corruption in two decades,
and the country is tied for second place on
the Corruption Perception Index.
But, of course, this is easier said than done.
High public salaries are a luxury most of
the world simply can’t afford.
It’s no coincidence that the countries at
the top of the list are also the world’s
wealthiest.
Of the top 10, for example, the poorest is
New Zealand, with a per capita GDP of $41,000.
China, on the other hand, discovered a much
cheaper solution.
One invisible to the Corruption Perception
Index, which lums a half-dozen different things
together under this nebulous umbrella term.
More interesting than how much ‘corruption’,
is what kind.
Yuen Yuen Ang, in her book “China’s Gilded
Age”, argues there are actually four distinct
types.
When the rich world hears the word ‘corruption’,
we imagine the 1% of the 1% — presidents,
prime ministers, and oligarchs — colluding
in poorly-lit rooms to siphon off public funds
for personal gain.
Yachts, mansions, and private jets.
That’s “Grand Theft”.
Conversely, people from lower-income regions
may not have to imagine.
They can simply remember a cop soliciting
bribes.
This is known as “Petty Theft”.
Whether small or large — theft is bad for
everyone but the thief.
When your leader embezzles public funds to
buy rare leopard-skin hats, you receive nothing.
But there’s another dimension: exchanges
— transactions in which the buyer receives
special treatment.
If you need 20 permits to open a restaurant,
you almost have to pay what’s called “Speed
Money” to overcome the red tape.
This is better than mere theft because at
least you get something in return.
You’re not worse off after paying the bribe.
Still, you’re certainly not celebrating.
But then there’s something called “Access
Money” — exchanges that make both parties
much better off.
Now, make no mistake: all corruption is ‘bad’,
but bad to who, when, and how?
If you’re a business, the theft kind is
just a loss — what economists would call
a tax.
Access money, on the other hand, is actually
an investment.
Suddenly you’re able to buy certain privileges
that you previously couldn’t.
And this kind is precisely what China has
the most of.
Here’s how it works:
At the top of each regional government, remember,
is a powerful elite, whose performance is
evaluated based on objective metrics like
economic growth.
The problem?
His or her next promotion requires the cooperation
of hundreds or thousands of poorly-paid subordinates.
What motivation does the bureaucrat making
80 bucks a month have to play along?
So, the two reach an agreement.
“Help me climb the ladder and I’ll make
sure you’re well taken care of”.
Government departments are allowed to operate
almost like independent businesses, keeping
some portion of whatever they collect in fees
and taxes.
Some of this money, in turn, is used to shower
workers with perks that would make even a
Google employee jealous.
Everything from food, to vacations, parties,
housing, electricity, gas, child care, furniture,
and equipment.
Although public wages are set below market
rates, formal salaries only comprise 24% of
the average bureaucrat’s total compensation.
When these unofficial benefits are included,
you can see they’re actually doing quite
well.
Bureaucrats may be short on cash, but that
doesn’t mean you won’t spot them on the
golf course or beach, sipping champagne.
But don’t lose the forest for the trees.
The point is not that government workers are
well-paid.
It’s that they receive a kind of unofficial
commission.
Every last cadre, no matter how low on the
org-chart, has a personal stake in the country’s
development.
Does your office need new computers?
Is your family due for a tropical vacation?
Chinese bureaucrats can and do extort businesses
for a few quick bucks, but the big money is
in attracting businesses, from whom most taxes
are generated.
Local governments ferociously compete to be
Tesla, IKEA, and Walmart’s best friend.
One province, for instance, introduced “leave
business alone days”, during which inspections
and other regulatory “intrusions” were
banned.
Another county’s slogan is, quote, "Investors
are Gods…bureaucrats are humble servants,
and those who harm corporate interests are
sinners”.
The genius of the Chinese system is that it
found an innovative way to harness corruption
for the ‘greater good’.
Paradoxically, this incredible economic growth
was made possible by millions of officials
using public funds to play blackjack in Macau
and buy designer handbags in Paris.
We think of the Chinese central government
as all-powerful and all-encompassing, able
to wield its authority far and wide.
But there remain practical and physical limits
to what’s possible.
Eliminating corruption is hard, if not impossible,
on a budget.
So, instead, China carefully manages which
kind is tolerated.
As you can clearly see, non-transactional
theft has been systematically targeted, while
business-friendly favors are left alone.
Likewise, just as bureaucrats are managed
by an imperfect combination of carrot and
stick, so too are individual citizens.
Chinese censorship is highly coercive, technologically
advanced, and effective.
But it’s not perfect, and surprisingly,
nor is it absolute.
Authoritarian governments like China’s are
a giant black box — shrouded in doubt and
secrecy.
But understanding what it does and doesn’t
censor is a rare and revealing reflection
of how the Communist Party thinks and what
it fears most.
This video has been about how China controls
its cadres.
This full-length Nebula Original about how
China controls its people is the very first
episode in my new series explaining how the
country actually works, starting by looking
underneath the black bar of censorship.
What gets censored, and even more interesting,
what doesn’t, and why?
The team and I have been working overtime
to bring you an additional Nebula-exclusive
video for every other one you see on YouTube.
These are full-length, normal PolyMatter videos,
not bonus, extended, or directors-cuts.
In other words, you can start getting 50%
more PolyMatter for just $12 bucks a year
right now for Mother’s Day by signing up
to CuriosityStream and Nebula.
On top of that, you’ll get access to dozens
of Nebula originals and exclusives, not to
mention ad-free videos from your favorite
creators.
On CuriosityStream you’ll find great feature-length
documentaries, like this one, about a Japanese
family who rents fake friends and spouses
for social events.
Click the link on screen right now to get
both Nebula and CuriosityStream for an amazing
fifteen bucks a year and go watch the companion
video over on Nebula.